hello everyone so today we're going to
talk about deep learning images for
Google compute engine and this is an
interesting topic in nature this topic
is interesting
many meetups and many activities usually
show by the end of the activity how to
build something something new and cool
but deep learning images is a tool too
that you have to use in your own
projects so probably today we're not
going to cover one particular cool thing
that you can build I will try to explain
the tool and I hope you guys will know
how to tell I this to in your own
projects so why are we going to speak
about the deep learning images times the
time we will be using different comments
that simplify my life when I'm working
with deep learning images and actually
just Google compute engine so this is a
link on the github page that has exactly
all the comments that I will be showing
today this link will be in the follow up
notes on the meetup so like if you don't
have a laptop and don't want to write it
right now it's absolutely ok this is QR
codes on the subway but I will show you
sir way slightly later you will see this
QR codes again let me start with
answering one main question what is deep
learning images so deep learning images
is basically set of different VM images
that has everything that you need for
doing your deep learning research out of
the box there are several key things
here this is not a one one image for
virtual machine this is set of images we
actually have different images this is a
graph that describe all of them and we
will come back to this graph later on
but just the key point this is not just
one image the second key point is that
is working out of the box so what does
it mean and why it's actually important
so let's meet Bob so this is a Bob Bob
wants to do a deep learning right to do
a deep learning he wants to build his
own virtual machine that has everything
that is needed for the planning in order
to do so if the Bob wants to do to use
the tensorflow
and the GPU he actually need to figure
out
which particular version of the CUDA is
required but tensorflow if anyone of you
in the past have tried to set up
yourself tensorflow with scooter you
probably do know that even figure out
which exact version of the code is
required is not a trivial task by the
way how many of you guys set up
tensorflow with GPU yourself on your
local machine mac OS or or in the cloud
okay quite a few good so you know the
pain next when you figure out the CUDA
you need to know which exact driver your
code is using and you need to install
that driver then you can start CUDA
then you need to figure out which exact
version of CUDA and then is required by
tens of roll a flow and a stolid and nco
starting with stanza flow 110 it will
actually not work if you're not going to
install correct and CL binary and then
you can finally install 10 the flow and
if something goes wrong probably it's
not going to work at all okay so let's
say our Bob has completed the setup of
the VM with several GPUs V 100 and the
setup looks like this so this is exact
setup that the Bob has completed tons of
for 1.9 CUDA 9.0 could Ian n7 no and CL
installed reasonable question to ask is
this the best possible configuration
that give you the most out of the money
that you're paying for the instance so
let's have a look for the baseline so
this is baseline of the speed this is
the configuration that we just discard
that the both Bob has if you switch to
Korean and 7.1 and latest nickel you
will have 10% performance boost on top
of it you had with original
configuration so then one may think okay
let's just use latest GU the latest
driver latest coup DNN and just forget
it it will give me the maximum
performance even though this thought my
appeared when the coup denied that one
was released you can see that night that
one actually slows down the tensor flow
so if you use if you used to use the
latest one by the time of coup denied
that one was out you are not using the
best possible configuration
and now if using latest 9:02 you
actually have 15% performance boost okay
how the Bob actually can figure this out
which the configuration is the best for
his particular instance if you want to
figure this out you need to compile
tensorflow there is no other way to use
different Cudas except to compile it
from the source
the official binary using only cuda 9.0
period you can use anything else then
you need to run an experiments with your
particular model on the instance to
figure out whether this new tensorflow
that you have compiled actually give you
any performance boost and you need to do
approximately an easy build
approximately 12 binaries you have three
different kudos you have two different
could enhance you who've you have two
different and CCL options and I've done
speaking about using Python to Python 3
so 12 binaries that you need to compile
from source and if new Nvidia stack is
released or new tensorflow is released
you need to start all these from scratch
because performance actually do change
with the new stack and this is exactly
where my team come to play we are
focusing precisely on figuring out which
particular configuration of deep
learning deep learning framework will
squeeze maximum performance out of the
hardware that we have on Google compute
engine so we're trying to figure out
with each particular new release how to
compile it so you will get maximum out
of your money if we compare what we have
from the Google compute engine within
our images to official tensorflow that
you can just download you will see the
difference with CUDA
we're using neither two while tons of
focus 9.0 we have the similar accordion
and we're using Nikken actually 1:10
efficient also starts using nickel we
using compell mkl just for cpu instances
and even if you don't know what is
Imperial mal on non GPU instances can
give you up to five time performance
boost like five times is just crazy when
you when you have something that worked
that fast comparing the official view
okay so this is what you get inside of
the images already
revealed configured and ready to work
now
one may ask where these deploy neck
images fit among all our other products
we have a good flow we have machine
learning engine we have call up and all
other different things that we're
providing on the market so if you look
on this magical line of different
products let's say the left move most
site is fully managed solution something
like machine monic engine or co-op and
the right hand side is a solution that
you have in your data centers your
machines and basically somewhere over
there on the right each side we have a
Google compute engine where you can spin
up the machine do whatever you want and
probably somewhere there we have good
flow with kubernetes it's not entirely
fully managed because you still have
access to the machine on GCE
even if you run in kubernetes and let me
show you the quote of this nice guy and
also who do remember when this quote
what was this quote about who do
remember this quote at all it is all
code that's ok ok ok see one yeah close
but actually maybe he said it twice who
knows but one thing that when he
mentioned this is when Google Cloud was
initially released we had only one
offering we have App Engine App Engine
was a really nice technology it was the
first server less technology on the
market out there but the thing is that
the customer were not entirely ready
they did not have resources to invest to
move all in at that time on the
brand-new new approach that they never
never have seen before
so then Eric Schmidt mentioned that ok
yes we do have this bright future but we
also need to meet our customer where
they are now
then Google cloud actually introduced
Google compute engine so this is where
our deep learning images are right now
they're in the sport where you have your
own solution you have your own research
files logic you have your own spin up
cluster solution that you do not want or
can not right now to move anywhere you
cannot invest right now but you have a
lot of legacy you need to run it
somewhere so if you do need to run it
with standard flow or with GPU just GPU
you are our customers because we will
produce the best image that can handle
it okay how to use it we have several
ways to use our images actually two main
main possible usage we are the UI or the
CLI your eyes pretty simple and self
exploratory I'm not going to actually
touch that part I am will focus on CLI
comment line interface and the stuff
that you need to that you need to know
so first thing that we need to do if you
want to create an instance with the
planning image figure out which
particular flavor you want to use this
is graph of the current flavors that we
providing right now so as you can see
with supporting two major frameworks
then the flow in a pie chart and if you
need something custom anything else
literally that requires CUDA we have
common flavors with different questions
of CUDA so first of all I need to figure
out which particular flavor you want to
use this is also called image family in
this particular example we're using
family tensorflow latest with SKU the
9.2 this is my family
specified and how many of you guys
creating have created have played with
influences on Google compute engine or
any other cloud providers in the past
quite a few good so if you creating
instance in Google compute engine you
have this ability to specify family of
the images you can think about family if
you have used docker is attack that
always points to the latest particular
can docker container and the reason why
I stopped here I want to speak about the
problem with using image family
or docker container stacks the thing is
if you always pointing at latest there
are chances that something like this
will come up eventually
this is numpy community that they
basically broadcasting to the world that
they're releasing humanum pie and this
new numpy have introduced a lot of a lot
of a lot of a lot of cleanups and this
may impact a lot of customers and
actually dunno customers who got
impacted because of this update of the
non piper sizes this one if you're using
family or if using docker container
latest probably the latest update
already includes this numpy because of
the security fixes that these numbers
has and it probably will break you so if
you're using either docker or our images
you probably need to switch from using
family directly on your production to
using the following pipeline three steps
you're getting latest image from the
family you're testing it with your
solution and then you're using interim
prod always like this never please never
use family directly if you using it on
the production production it doesn't
mean something that's served traffic
from me to day production is my my demo
that they're going to show and for my
demo I'm going to use particular exact
image there is a comment that allows you
to extract exactly the image name and
for today I'm going to use data flow
latest CPU and exact hash this is the
image that basically I'm going to use
and now I'm switching my comment from
family to actual name second one image
project we have some customers who
actually when they creating an instance
setting project to their project but
this is the project that hosts the
images which is ours maintain policy the
thing is if using GPU your instance
cannot be life immigrated to another
hard or machine this is very important
you need to notice and take into account
if you're using GPU in case of
maintenance the only way is to actually
terminate your instance next part if you
want to create an instance of creating
you setting up how or what the
accelerator then you want to
use this is an important part because
you need to not only to choose
particular accelerator from the forward
we have you need to educate yourself
about the regions that they are exist if
you specifying their own region where
accelerator doesn't exist it will not
work and after setting the correct
region the correct accelerator you need
to set up with the correct amount of
accelerator that you will attach the
instance if the amount does not exist
again you can create the instance with
for instance Tesla be 104 Tesla 100 we
not when we do not support these
configurations yet and the last one this
part is basically giving permission to
Google on your behalf to install Nvidia
driver
the thing is images come with free come
pre-installed CUDA CUDA and everything
should proceed up and tested except the
Nvidia driver there are some reasons why
it's have been done this way I am NOT
going to drive to that particular region
sorry reason but without this flock you
will not have nvidia driver on the
instance installed now what else you can
you can tune you can set preemptable
flock if you need preemptable is
basically who knows the concept of
preemptable instances ok
so Google compute engine had this
concept of preemptable instances where
you actually buying the same instance
but for the cheaper price with only one
one downside this instance can be
switched off at any point of time so yes
I personally thank that I'm writing
printable instances and they drink a lot
of model dares but time the time it
might be switched off without any any
anyway now keep in mind that if you have
a quota when you when you creating a
GPUs you need to request aquatic water
for preemptable instance are not equal
to quota to normal and normal instances
if you have a quota for NVDA P 100 you
do need to have quota for preemptable
immediate P 100 in order to
start premature for instance next if
you're going to run the comment like
this you will get this small is possible
instance I think this guy has one core
and less than one gigabyte memory so if
you want you can attach any supported
machine type next you want to say you
have the ability to set up type of the
disk this is actually SSD we do have
support of local SSD disk with which
away faster scuzzy disk this is
basically some of the measurement and
the speed that we can guarantee you with
the local SSD disk and the most
importantly we have introduced new type
of local city disk that actually using
can have nvm i connection to the to the
instance and it gives you so the one on
the top with the old one the one on the
bottom then you want I want to say twice
faster but significally faster which is
important if you're training something
that me requires read data from from the
disk and the last one scopes these
scopes is actually required if you want
to use TP use and here I actually going
to switch for just a second to the
console I'm going to create TP you not
I'm going to create a pin not because
we're going to use it in several minutes
and since it takes to create ATP not
several minutes let me just start my TP
you not right now and let me press setup
Network and press create
now the question sorry when you say when
you specifying these metadata that they
just mentioned a stong video drivers
through your giving permission for the
google to install driver for you a lot
of the customers who actually has a
cluster with many machine in the cluster
they're kind of critical for the time to
boot if you have a four machine each of
the four machine has eight volt IV 100
and it have time to boot equal to three
minutes you already paying for twelve
minutes
yeah for machines twelve minutes
just for boot time so one of the common
question okay how I can reduce time of
the boot from my machine
and the answer is simple we getting the
image that you want to create instance
from from the Google cloud we can create
the blonic instance waiting until the
driver is installed three five minutes
it's horrible we're working on this and
this will be improved stopping the
instance and creating own Diplo neck
image out of that instance that simple
5-step and you have your own image and
that image will have this famous
15-second startup time that GC gives you
on other images okay now the main parts
let actually see how we can use it the
first I will show you japaese lab who
have used here Jupiter notebooks or
Jupiter lab nice so the most important
part is to be developed so let's
actually create the instance and use it
so I have copy pasted one comment
exactly the comment that I just showed
you on the slides let me make it bigger
bigger so I have my image I have
instance name I have dawn let's go and
create it this way it should take maybe
twenty seconds or half a minute marks
because this is a CPU instance is not
going to install to install the Nvidia
driver this is a common that they
originally showed to you this part are
not required if you if you are not using
GPUs so basically this is the at the end
common okay let's see if the instance
shop nope
usually faster three for the second to
do okay
while we waiting this is a small
improvement one of the common that they
mentioned to you on my github comment
that allows you to search to the
instance is just slightly nicer to say
gee is a sage and set to g-cloud compute
Association the name of the instance
just a small improvement that you'll
find on the github page okay in order to
connect to the instance you
have to run this jssh instance name
subscribed on and the port mapping this
is the only one thing that you need to
do after your instance is up in order to
start using jupiter lab instances up
so let's actually let's actually do it
let me copy paste my commands we
connecting to the images live let's go
to the browser
let's open localhost 8080 and here's
jupiter you have a jupiter if you would
create the instance with GPU he will
have GPU be 100 you literally don't need
to do anything else except starting your
instance we're already spinning up the
jupiter in the background that is
listening on port 8080 the only thing
that is left to do for you is actually
to open your browser that's literally
now next use case next use case it the
coop who have used coop okay so for
those of you who have not let me show
what kalapas collab with the google
service that basically is a notebook at
the cloud it's very similar to the
notebooks it's actually provides similar
use case but it's completely hosted so
you don't have a machine behind but this
creates some implications let me show
you exactly the implications so if you
have a google cloud project and you have
your machine you have TPU inside and you
want to use it with the collab you
cannot because the collab doesn't have
any notion about about google cloud
project it does not understand that you
have a Google two coil project it cannot
connect to any resources there however
you do have a laptop and your laptop do
have a connection to your instance with
port mapping 8080 that we just saw
precisely for the reason of opening
Jupiter lab and your instance do have
connection to GPU so now the last part
that is missing
is to connect all up to your laptop on
port 8080 and this is exactly the
functionality that we have released
several weeks ago we now have the
ability to use our deep learning images
as a back-end for the collab and it
works very very simple let me go back to
the collab so this is an official collab
let me let me increase the font let me
double check that this is official
collab let's see
version of the Tanzer flow that actually
install here do-do-do-do-do-do-do he's
doing something and I hope it will
eventually will work it should be 1.9
yes it's 1.9 because it's official
version in the cloud now let me press
connect to the local runtime basically
what this will do it will connect collab
to my local runtime and the port is 8080
and my machine right now the port 8080
has a mirror of the port 8080 of Diplo
mnek VM instance that we had let me
press connect
that's it now the collab is using remote
machine and therefore we will have
tensorflow
1.9 that we just have released in our DM
images yesterday together we'll just
enter for 1 to 10 so yes 1 to 10 by the
way got released if you follow income
the news
this basically means so now you can use
collab with anything you want including
pi torch any possible GPU and even TP
use since they set now we're using
deploy make image of the backend let me
create a brand new the notebook in the
collab and just to show that we do have
a TPU access to the TPU
I will run one cell and we can run it
here on the one cell that will connect
to the TPU let me first get my IP
address
oh the same 10011 yes it's the same yes
it's actually connected so it works so
now you can use collab with the TPU is
you can do whatever you want in the
collab with deep learning images pi
torch any possible GPUs now another
question that we usually have from the
customers so the VM images how do i do
anaconda I want using a condom this is
nice
the anaconda scenarios has some problem
and the reason of this problem if you
install on a condom if you're creating a
new virtual environment inside of there
the condom you need to install
tensorflow within that environment how
do you do this if you're going to
install official tensorflow
it will not work because official
tensorflow requires cuda 9.0 and we have
nine - - in order to support this we are
actually providing a binary our Google
compute engine optimized binary that are
pre baked inside of the image so you
will have the ability to install them so
this is a small script that we do have
an official documentation that basically
setting the path that we were reprieve
aching the binary and then you just can
run people style inside of your anaconda
environment okay next how you can get
help if you stop we have a many
different channel to support you guys we
do have official dogs of course but if
you want some something else
I have several blocks when I actively
adding different use cases for our
images we do have dedicated Stack
Overflow tag which we actively
monitoring please do submit questions
there
we do have an pretty active Google group
with different users who might help you
even before I my colleagues will spot
the question you can always pin me even
on personal Twitter I would really
appreciate any questions you can send me
a mail and I I will I will answer any
possible ways for you guys okay in short
overview deep learning images is the pre
baked images that has everything ready
to start with different IDs Jupiter lock
jupiter notebook co-op backend
and almost any framework that you can
that you can imagine now this is the
survey which is really really important
if you can guys help us to understand
what you want to see in the future
version of the view of the VM images
what you want us to add as a unit test
which case scenario you want us to
support please do participate in the
survey thank you then this is all from
my side guys thank you for coming I hope
there is more pizza still left and I
hope to see you next time
[Music]
you